Chris Khai Lai, ra chỉ khắp miệt và cực hiếm xe sau mối bán.
Thì chương bất động sản ngày càng để cao tình an toàn và miếng bạnh, những giữa ăn có ra chỉ hình dữ đăng trở thành lựa trọn lực y tình.
Chris Khai Lai là dựa ăn hiếm hoai khi hòa thiện toàn bộ công chính trước thời điểm mối bán,
suối mua có thể chức tiếp kiểm chính chức lượng không giản sống và hệ tựa ích sẽ vận hành thực tế trước khi ra quyết địch.
Dự ăn được phát triển bội tì bếp lành thành viên của tì bếp rút, tập đoàn đăng ngày năm trong tốt năm nhà sản xuất công nghiệp toàn cầu.
Chính nên tảng vững chắc này, Zoo Prince Khai Lai sắc lập mô trình mực sống mối được kinh tạo từ bộ bà sả sị,
sản phẩm thật, ra chỉ thật, tránh nghiệm thật bảo chứng bằng quy tín thương hiệu và tâm nghiên phát triển dài hạn của tì bếp.
Prince Khai Lai năm trong khu đô thiện Prince Khai đã hiện hiểu với ba mặt tiền đường khuốc lộ một ca,
người ETH Một, người ETH Năm. Đây là khu vực có mất đổ dân cực ca, hả tự hoàn chính và giống trảy ra thương suối động.
Prince Khai Lai sử dữ lợi thế giới mối có trên chức khuốc lộ một ca khi mọi tự ích trong hiểu đều năm trong khoảng cách đi bộ.
Ngay dưới trên nhà là phố Muà Sắm, Ghosy Anh, thêm bài bước dí trình tiếp cận hai bệnh viện đã khoảng hòa nĩ.
Kế bên là là đại học Quốc gia thành phố Xí Minh, nơi hội tụi cộng đồng trưng ra, rằng viên và chỉ thức đông đồng,
tạo nên như cầu lưu chú và tìm năng cho thêm bình bước.
Tại đây, khách hàng có thể trảy giệm trận vệnh khuốc dành sống theo phong cách CT, Kui Zoth,
đồng thời khai thác và sự dụng ngày sau khi được bằng giáu nhạm với thời gian sự kiến vào 18 năm 2020.
Bởi pháp li vững bằng, đủ điều khiển bán hàng cụm bức giá Trung bình sau viết tâm,
sự đồng trên mấy phố trong một tổ ấm đã hoàn thiệt bằng giao cao cấp và vận hành theo chừng phích sản năm sau.
Rồi, cài lai được xem là lựa trọn phố hợp cho cả như cầu ăn cư lẫn đầu tư.
Một dạng hạnh phúc, trên đời với giá chị mình vẫn sống hành cùng như phát triển đối thị của khu vực.